[Music]
millions of images of video national
center for missing and exploited
children usb ports of the world of the
internet is packed with section of
investigation
that in Germany
this data is stored for a maximum of seven days so that
we have several thousand per year
de facto not being able to dissolve that is of
course not easy for us to
deal with the burden because of course you
always have
the concert data centers truck necessary
investigation in the background
it's about creating a transparent
person and
revealing all the secrets about it that's it  not but
it's really
just a kind of itemized bill that you need when has who uses which ip address with which internet to be able to assign the retro degree
and the advantage that
you can draw from
it lies in my opinion the disadvantages
concerns by far the
police are still working to crack mode  rn
500 terabytes of data room services
professional level in crèches when
it comes to securing carriers that
also have such
encryption then it is
always expected that the law
enforcement authorities will be
able to decrypt them without further ado and that
is not the case and  i face
this problem but not only we
face this problem law
enforcement authorities worldwide and
actually it is rather the exception
that it actually succeeds
in cracking such an encryption
increased the past couple of germany
invest lissavetzky die mauern average
if the cases of reported
child pornography did
then it is imperative that you
adapt the staff to the equipment accordingly
the more staff you have to mediate in this area the more criminal offenses you will also
be able to mediate because otherwise
you will no longer be able to deal with the matter data
loss of investigations a  few days the
street and technology studies in the
german police facebook and twitter to
report eli posted
certainly ist
[music]